[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le grand jeu en ce qui concerne le
changement climatique ces deux capables
de fonctionner en arrêtant d'émettre des
gaz à effet de serre par un tout petit
peu et arrêter d'émettre des gaz à effet
de serre il ya une abréviation
maintenant qui est passé dans le langage
courant qui consiste à dire être bas
carbone
c'est ça arrêter d'émettre des gaz à
effet de serre alors la bonne nouvelle
c'est que absolument tout le monde va
devenir bas carbone un jour soit parce
qu'on le veut ou soit précisément parce
qu'on ne veut pas vous avez ici trois
courbes qui vous donne pour le monde
dans son ensemble ce que coûte l'énergie
rapportait à ce que les gens gagnent
alors la totalité de ce que les gens
gagnent c'est ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler le pib j'y reviendrai un peu
plus tard dans cet exposé mais le pib
c'est par définition en comptabilité la
valeur de la totalité de ce que vous
vendez et du coup comme on ne paye que
des hommes je reviendrai aussi c'est la
totalité de ce que les gens gagnent et
donc ce que vous dépensez pour acheter
de l'énergie que vous voyez là eh bien
c'est ce que vous coûte l'énergie quand
votre rapport à l'énergie c'est juste de
payer une facture
si je prends une période hors choc
pétrolier que je met tout ça bout taguba
bon an mal an ça me coûte quelques
pourcents de ce que je gagne on s'en
fout no big deal
parce que à partir du moment où vous
vous dites l'énergie c'est quelques
pourcents de ce que je gagne
eh bien le réflexe logique que vous
allez avoir juste derrière c'est ça vaut
le coup demande occupé quelques pour
cent du temps du temps je m'en fous
beaucoup de sujets sérieux ce qu'on va
faire avec les retraites avec l'école
avec jeu pourquoi la paix dans le monde
on va voir dans pas longtemps que
l'énergie pilote le reste vous avez le
même genre de raisonnement totalement
stupide en économie quand on vous dit
l'agriculture c'est 2% du pib donc on
s'en fout enfin si je vous empêche de
manger pendant suffisamment longtemps je
pense que le reste du pib va commencé à
flageoler un peu si vous êtes dans cette
salle c'est justement parce qu'on n'a
pas économisé l'énergie
si on avait économisé l'énergie c'est à
dire si on n'avait pas commencé à se
vautrer dans les combustibles fossiles
et bien au lieu d'être ici à m'écouter
vous seriez et raté chez vous dans votre
chaudière après une journée à ramasser
les patates il y aurait pas les machines
corp et bosser pour vous toute la
journée pour vous faire vos vêtements le
métro qui vous a amené ici la salle dans
laquelle nous sommes et qui a été
construit très rapidement et c'est tout
ça ça n'existerait pas sans aide
abondante donc on serait toujours une
civilisation agraire et à l'heure qu'il
est vous seriez éreinté donc la raison
pour laquelle vous êtes aujourd'hui dans
cette salle avec le temps de venir
écouter mais ça en est c'est justement
parce que nous n'avons pas économiser
l'énergie
alors ça veut pas dire qu'à l'avenir
c'est pas un sujet ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est que quand on dit la
meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme pas c'est une appréciation
relative c'est pas une règle absolue au
regard de ce qui a été l'histoire des
hommes
l'énergie c'est ce qui me permet d'agir
sur le monde parce que l'énergie en
physique
l'énergie est une grandeur physique
avant d'être quoi que ce soit d'autre
l'énergie c'est donc soumis à des lois
qui ne dépendent pas de nous donc en
fait l'énergie c'est par définition ce
qui caractérise la transformation du
monde c'est ça sa définition
l'énergie c'est ce qui caractérise tous
qui quantifie plus exactement la
transformation du monde donc de
l'énergie va entrer en jeu dès que vous
allez modifier une température une forme
une vitesse une couleur n'importe quoi
dès que vous avez une transformation
dans le monde qui vous entoure vous avez
de l'énergie qui entrent en jeu
donc dès que vous êtes capable de
mobiliser de l'énergie en fait vous êtes
capable d'influer sur votre destin et
c'est la raison pour laquelle les hommes
ont cherché à en utiliser de plus en
plus tant qui avait pas de limite au
système qu'ils étaient en train de
manipuler la loi de conservation elle
vous dit quelque chose d'extrêmement
simple elle vous dit que quand vous êtes
dans un système qui ne communiquent pas
avec l'extérieur l'énergie se conserve
c'est ça la loi de conservation c'est
très très simple d'accord donc à
l'intérieur d'un système qui ne
communiquent pas avec le reste vous ne
pouvez ni créer ni détruire de l'énergie
alors prenez l'humanité tant que
l'humanité ne communique pas avec
l'extérieur
elle ne peut pas créer d'énergie et donc
en fait ce qu'on appelle utiliser de
l'énergie c'est l'extraire de
l'environnement où elles existent déjà
toute énergie que nous utilisons sur
terre
absolument tout y compris notre propre
alimentation est une énergie qui vient
de l'environnement où elle près existe
déjà c'est tout ce qu'on a le droit de
faire d'accord sinon on viole la
première loi de la thermo ce qui est
quand même un peu ennuyeux cette énergie
vous allez la faire rentrer dans ce
qu'on appelle un convertisseur c'est à
dire une machine qui va la prendre sous
la forme sous laquelle elle elle absorbe
et en faire autre chose alors si la
machine c'est vous vous rentrez
l'énergie sous forme chimique
c'est l'énergie contenue dans les
aliments
vous allez en faire deux choses de la
chaleur parfaitement renouvelables votre
corps à 37 degrés et un peu de mouvement
pas beaucoup en fait si vous regardez en
part relative dans l'énergie qui sort de
votre corps c'est essentiellement de la
chaleur au début donc le seul
convertisseur auquel les hommes ont eu
accès c'était eux mêmes avec le temps
quelques brillants ingénieurs ont trouvé
d'autres convertisseur énergétique
capable d'utiliser d'autres sources
d'énergie que les hommes encore une fois
ne peuvent pas exploiter en direct quand
un français consomme du pétrole en fait
il mobilise à son profit une machine qui
consomment du pétrole c'est ça qui fait
en vérité
donc il faut deux choses pour que on
augmente la consommation d'énergie il
faut d'une part qu'on ait inventé le
convertisseur qui permet de s'en servir
et d'autre part il faut que l'on diffuse
le nombre de convertisseur qui s'en
servent
et puis bien sûr il faut que les
d'énergie préexiste dans l'environnement
et donc augmenter sa consommation
d'énergie en fait ce que vous devez
comprendre ces j'augmente le parc de
machines dont je suis en train de me
servir directement ceux qui sont en
train de taper sur leur smartphone au
lieu de m'écouter c'est pas bien
les quelques caméras qui tourne et c est
surtout un directement parce que quand
vous avez enfilé un vêtement ce matin
vous avez indirectement mobilisés à
votre profit des milliers de machines
tout ce qui va du puits de pétrole
jusqu'aux vêtements si c'est du poly
machin chouette et tout ce qui va du
chant jusqu'aux vêtements 6 et du coton
du lin je peux vous dire qu'il ya des
milliers de machines qui ont bossé pour
que vous enfilez vos vêtements le matin
et je vais vous montrer ça avec un petit
calcul très simple qui va comparer
l'énergie mécanique capable de sortir de
vos jambes et qu'une machine est capable
de nous fournir
je vous mets un petit sac à dos sur le
dos et je vous fais monter 2000 m de
dénivelé donc si vous faites ça et bien
à la fin de la journée vous aurez
restitués grâce à vos jambes à ridicule
demi kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
un ridicule estime devrais je dire demi
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique tout
petit nous sommes tout petits
donc si nous n'avions pas les machines
pour agir sur l'environnement
l'environnement on aurait pas de
problème avec si vous faites ça un jour
sur deux et bien la fin de l'année vous
aurez fournit 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie mécanique avec vos jambes donc
si jamais quelqu'un au travail de force
pour modifier de la matière creuser des
trous
des arbres les transporter et ses
plantes et du blé whatever et bien cette
personne va pouvoir me fournir dans
l'année 100 kilowatts heure de
transformation de l'environnement
puisque je vous ai dit que l'énergie
c'est par définition la transformation
de l'environnement
si maintenant je prends monsieur
schwarzenneger et que je lui demande de
me décaissés 15 tonnes de terre tous les
jours
eh bien il est dix fois plus ridicule
que mon alpinistes qui précède puisque à
la fin de la journée il aura restituer
0.05 kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
et s'il fait ça un jour sur deux et bien
à la fin de l'année il mort a fourni 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique et
bien 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie non
pas mécanique mais thermique
c'est ce que j'obtiens en brûlant à
litre d'essence
vous avez dit kilowattheures d'énergie
thermique donc de chaleur et cette
chaleur vous allez la transformer en
mouvement dans un moteur et monsieur
carnot a dit pas de chance vous aurez
pas 10 kilowatts heure de mouvements à
la fin c'est interdit vous en aurez
entre 2 et 4 c'est déjà pas mal
parce que ça veut dire que dans 1 litre
d'essence qui vaut le prix scandaleux
d'un euro quelque chose vous avez la
même capacité à transformer
l'environnement
c'est ça que ça veut dire la même que ce
que vous avez dans 10 à 100 jours de
travail de force d'un individu alors
vous savez qu'en france on est tous
nucléaire donc j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous dans un pays où d'une tout
nucléaire on consomme pas de pétrole
évidemment sinon n'est pas tout
nucléaire
ils sont qu'un français consomment mille
litres de pétrole par an en moyenne ce
qu'il me faut payer pour extraire un
kilowattheure de l'environnement
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique de
l'environnement si je passe par un homme
une femme
je vais payer quelques centaines à
quelques milliers d'euros par
kilowattheure mécanique extrait de
l'environnement si j'utilise une
carcasse humaine en la payant au smic
alors que dans le même temps si
j'extrais ce kilowattheure de
l'environnement avec une machine qui
fonctionne au pétrole ou si je
transforme l'environnement autour d'un
kilowattheure pour le plus précis et
bien ça va me coûter moins d'un euro
beaucoup moins d'un euro de l'ordre du
dixième d'euros et cette énergie dans la
vision que je vous propose
elle a même fait quelque chose de très
profond dans les relations sociales
elle a supprimé l'escalavage si je
prends un esclave je vais devoir payer
pour aller chercher cette personne
contre sa volonté
je vais devoir payer devoir d investir
des moyens pour l'empêcher de motricité
ou tout le camp et puis je vais devoir
faire ce qu'il faut pour que cette
personne reste vivante donc la nourrir
la vêtir la loger etc
donc même si je paye pas son travail
quand même payer quelque chose eh bien
ce quelque chose mis bout-à-bout si vous
faites ce calcul parfaitement sordide
j'en conviens mais quand même éclairant
et bien vous vous rendez compte que même
un esclave va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois
plus cher que la machine
la raison pour laquelle on a supprimé
l'esclavagisme dans l'essentiel des pays
du monde c'est pas du tout parce que
vous êtes devenu bon alors que vos
ancêtres étaient malfaisants méchant
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous on ne
recourt pas à cette forme de rapports
humains alors que eux ils recouraient
c'est parce que à l'époque ça avait un
intérêt économique que ça n'a plus haut
salat plus du tout aujourd'hui
j'imagine que je fais souffle et se vend
à 80 km heure c'est à dire un peu plus
de 40 noeuds et que je fais passer
souvent dans une éolienne qui va donc
récupérer une partie de l'énergie
cinétique de l'air en mouvement et bien
la quantité d'énergie que je vais
pouvoir récupérer de la sorte avec un
roman de 40% de l'éolienne
c'est la même chose que ce que j'ai dans
3000 litres de pétrole alors les progrès
techniques permettront peut-être de
faire mieux mais je rappelle que les
progrès techniques aujourd'hui son dû à
l'énergie fossile
si vous arrivez à faire vos éoliennes
plus vite et moins cher c'est parce que
vous allez utiliser plus de moyens
techniques donc de pétrole de gaz et de
charbon pour faire vos éoliennes vous
signale que le pétrole est aussi
gratuite le vent personne dans cette
salle n'a payé le moindre centime pour
que le pétrole existe donc le pétrole
est aussi gratuit que le vent ce qui
coûte dans tous les cas de figure c'est
d'aller le chercher
le jour vous n'aurez plus que des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes pour
faire la métallurgie la mine la chimie
amont et c'est pour refaire des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes on en
reparlera du mégawatt heure solaire à 15
euros 1
parce que ce qui coûte très cher avec
des sources non pilotable cd ronde
pilotable il se trouve qu'il ya deux
siècles
nous avons déjà fait une première fois
une expérience 100 % venaient on a
besoin de l'ademe à l'époque on a
vraiment fait un monde 100% venayre donc
je peux vous dire l'expérience
fonctionne on l'a fait une fois
à l'époque on était cinq cents millions
d'agriculteurs 30 ans d'espérance de vie
à la naissance mais donc on l'a déjà
fait une fois donc c'est absolument
certain que ça marche 100% le vénère
pour les fans de se gratter la tête
est ce que ça marche pour 7 milliards d'
au moins industrialis ça c'est une
question
la raison pour laquelle on est passé des
énergies renouvelables merveilleuse aux
énergies fossiles diabolique
elle est là c'est que vous avez besoin
de mobiliser 100 fois moins de monde
pour sortir l'énergie de l'environnement
et donc vous êtes capable d'augmenter la
ductilité de tous les autres tous les
autres terriens grâce aux machines et
vous êtes capable d'offrir le niveau de
vie que vous avez la civilisation dans
laquelle 70 % des gens sont occupés à
extraire de l'énergie de l'environnement
ça s'appelle une civilisation agricole
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que il ya
un siècle et demi
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne et surtout le fait de bois et
se boit c'est essentiellement à produire
de la chaleur donc avec on se chauffe
on commence également à faire
fonctionner des forges à faire
fonctionner les premières machines à
vapeur
mais quand même avec ça en fait beaucoup
de chaleur est ce que vous voyez c'est
que à part le bois qui ramenait à
l'individu a baissé en un siècle et demi
toutes les autres énergies que nous
avons commencé à mobiliser à notre
profit il y en a pas une
en gros qu'ils aient cédé la place à une
autre jamais la quantité de charbon
utilisé par personne n'a été aussi
élevée qu'aujourd'hui et je peux vous
dire que c'est vrai également en france
puisque à chaque fois que vous achetez
un produit qui a été et made in china il
a été made in châ rebond aujourd'hui le
charbon ne décroît pas pour une raison
assez simple et on le verra tout à
l'heure c'est que les deux tiers du
charbon utilisé sur terre servent à
alimenter les centrales électriques
alors là aussi vous peut-être pas dans
cette salle mais l'essentiel des gens à
qui on dit électricité dans le monde
ils pensent nucléaire il pense
éventuellement éolien or il se trouve
que dans le monde
la première est de loin un source de
production électrique fait appel au
charbon au charbon on a rajouté le
pétrole pétrole n'a pas du tout
supprimer le charbon ne sera ajouté par
dessus alors pourquoi parce que le
pétrole ne sert pas du tout la même
chose que le charbon le pétrole à cause
de son extraordinaire densité
énergétique par unité de volume par
unité de poids plus exactement
eh bien il sert à outrance port avant
tout l'essentiel de ceux qui se
déplacent sur terre utilisent du pétrole
100% des avions 100 % de ceux qui
naviguent et 90% de ce qui roule en gros
utilise du pétrole donc tout ça a mis
bout-à-bout fait que 98 % de l'énergie
qu'on utilise pour se déplacer c'est du
pétrole lorsque vous voyez là c'est
ramener à l'individu l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial agrégé de l'éolien
du photovoltaïque du
moteur du marais moteur du biogaz de la
géothermie
sauf les deux grandes énergies
renouvelables qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
dans le monde c'est-à-dire le bois et
l'hydroélectricité
donc c'est tout le reste alors faisons
vite l'accord de paris en maintenant
votre confort de vie c'est-à-dire au
premier ordre
votre quantité d'énergie utilisée par
personne c'est à dire aux premiers
ordres à quantité de machines que vous
utilisez chaque jour ça revient à ce que
le petit machin violer la supprime tout
le reste en 35 ans l'essentiel de ce qui
fait votre niveau de vie c'est de
carbone l'essentiel donc je vais vous le
dire d'une autre manière
les deux degrés s'est organisé une
récession massive donc la vérité
indicible derrière ce graphique c'est
que le niveau de vie du smicard français
n'est pas durable quelle était la taille
de la population mondiale quand vous
apprenez à l'école primaire alors que
les plus jeunes dans cette salle on leur
à 17 milliards
à mon époque c'était plus de 3 et à
l'époque de mes parents c'est plutôt 2
quand même monté très vite je regarde
quelle est l'énergie qui augmente le
plus sur les 15 dernières années
vous savez bien qu'on installe les
éoliennes cette charbon qui a plus
augmenté sur les 15 dernières années
enfin les 16 juste derrière on va
trouver une deuxième énergies fossiles
le gaz juste derrière une troisième
énergies fossiles ce que j'ai appelé au
ici en fait c'est des liquides mais peu
importe c'est les carburants
la première énergies renouvelables vient
loin derrière et soit dit en passant
c'est d'hydroélectricité et la grande
hydraulique
on peut débattre sur c'est très grandes
vertus environnementales
en fait comme l'énergie c'est par
définition transformer ce qui nous
entoure
le drame c'est que dès que vous
transformez beaucoup vous avez beaucoup
de sous produits et beaucoup d'effets
indésirables
donc toute énergie devient salle dès
lors qu'elle devient massivement
utilisés y en a pas une qui fait
exception parce que par définition
utilisée plein d'énergie
c'est beaucoup perturber l'environnement
alors avec quoi fait-on d'électricité
aujourd'hui pour 40% avec du charbon
laâyoune équivalence 1 pour 1 que vous
pouvez garder en mémoire un
kilowattheure au charbon à kg de co2
c'est simple un peu moins des fois comme
c'est très efficace avec du gaz deux
fois moins pas mal encore avec du
pétrole vous voyez que ce soit dit en
passant la quantité en valeur absolue de
kilowattheures qui sortent des centrales
au fioul s'est presque
la même chose qu'il ya trente ans en
part relative s'est blessé après la
première grand d'électricité bas carbone
dans le monde c'est l'hydroélectricité
la deuxième c'est le nucléaire et après
vous allez trouver les trucs qui sont
là-haut alors le solaire c'est le truc
orange là si vous avez mis vos bois de
lunettes ou que vous avez une bonne vue
et le grand paradoxe est que ces
énergies sont pas du tout décarbonés
nécessairement enfin pas du tout très
décarbonés parce qu'il faut fabriquer le
panneau fabriqué l'éolienne et si en
plus vous stockez faut fabriquer la
batterie donc vous avez deux facteurs de
production c'est pas comme ça qu'on
apprend l'économie les deux facteurs de
production le capital et le travail
et hop le supermarché rempli mais donc
monsieur du pain il disserte nous avons
des hommes et des femmes dans le temps
ce peu importe mais nous avons également
des machines alors à l'époque les
machines c'est des moulins envoyé avant
hydraulique etc des machines à vapeur et
il dit si je transforme ça en équivalent
carcasse en équivalent esclaves en
équivalent au mot travail
eh bien vous voyez que je rajoute à la
population française 5 millions d'hommes
virtuel et à la population grande
bretonne 20 millions d'hommes virtuel
voilà donc monsieur du pain s'il avait
conçu le système économique mondial il
n'aurait pas du tout raisonner de la
même manière il aura lieu certes en
sortie j'ai une production
sauf que pour produire j'ai besoin des
ressources à transformer donc monsieur
du pas un n'aurait pas oublier que pour
faire des meubles en bois il faut du
bois et pas juste des investissements
dans les scieries et monsieur du pain il
aurait également dit il faut cette
capacité à transformer les ressources
que j'appelle le travail moi j'ai rien
inventé avec les systèmes énergétiques
et tous ceux qui ont parlé d'esclaves
énergétique avant moi jusqu'à monsieur
du pain on vient d'inventer non plus
prenez un tracteur le premier tracteur
venue quelques dizaines de kilos at
savoure en place quelques centaines de
paires de jambes ou quelques dizaines
d'animaux très raison pour laquelle dès
que vous augmenter l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans un pays vous voyez la
fraction de la population active qui
bosse dans l'agriculture qui baisse
c'est mécanique
ça se passe comme ça parte avec un tel
différentiel d'efficacité entre l'homme
et la machine
vous n'avez besoin de travail que pour
piloter les machines au travail et si
l'approvisionnement énergétique baisse à
vous explique ce paradoxe qui est que si
l'approvisionnement énergétique se met à
baisser de manière subi il ya moins de
machines qui peuvent bosser et du
vous avez besoin de monde la première
pensée qui viendrait à l'esprit - inclus
pendant longtemps c'était de dire si je
baisse l'approvisionnement énergétique à
moins de machines au boulot donc ça
libère de l'espace pour les hommes mais
non dans un univers de prix de marché ça
marche pas parce que le prix des matchs
le prix de la production des machines
résiduelles celles qui sont toujours
capable de bosser reste tellement bas
que ça ne rentre toujours pas l'homme
compétitif donc tout ce que vous faites
quand l'approvisionnement énergétique
baisse dans un monde de machines avec un
tel écart de productivité entre l'homme
et la machine
c'est vous créer du chômage ce qui veut
dire que ceux qui transforment au
premier ordre le monde qui nous entoure
c'est pas vous c'est les machines vous
vous ne servez à rien d'autre qu'à
piloter des machines si vous avez un
goulet d'étranglement sur l'énergie eh
bien vous avez moins de machines au
travail et donc moins de pib
nonobstant le fait que vous votiez les
fesses des chômeurs pour qu'ils aillent
bosser et nonobstant le fait que vous
votiez les fesses des banquiers pour que
ils investissent ah oui il faut alors
temps vous avez plein d'énergie pib
augmente
vous avez ici un nuage de points c'est
un nuage de points si si sûr que ça
décrit une droite et c'est le meilleur
modèle macroéconomique que je connaisse
c'est la date c'est le seul qui ait
prédictif serre que le jour où je suis
tombé sur ce truc là j'ai dit ben voila
quand l'approvisionnement énergétique
augmente le pib augmenter depuis six
sept huit ans que je suis trop classe ça
marche extrêmement bien
l'approvisionnement mondial augmente pib
augmente parce que plus d'énergie plus
de machines au travail
et comme chaque machine au travail
transforme et que dans les entreprises
cette transformation s'appelle de la
valeur ajoutée et que l'empilement des
valeurs ajoutées cette pib ça vous au
groupe le pays des vous voyez que
l'énergie et le pib kovarik sur terre
alors que bien évidemment la force de
travail
année après année ne varie pas de
manière aussi régulière là vous voyez
bien que la quantité de machines au
travail c'est à dire l'énergie
zig zag il fortement d'une année sur
l'autre et donc le pib c'est à dire le
produit de ces machines zigzag oui
fortement d'une année sur l'autre
vous avez ici la production économique
reconstitué depuis la naissance de
monsieur jésus-christ est ce que vous
voyez c'est que pendant très très
longtemps on n'avait pas de machine à
leur disposition donc la production
mondiale augmentait aussi vite que les
hommes au travail et les hommes au
travail ça augmentait pas vite donc
essentiellement le pib n'augmenter pas
et alors la craque on est parti pour 3 %
par an et la démocratie athénienne ou
romaine
c'était juste une poignée de citoyens
libres assis sur une armée d'esclaves
donc l'histoire a retenu les gens là qui
parler de la pluie et du beau temps dans
l'agora
ils ont juste oublié que ces gens là
étaient assis sur une armée d'esclaves
qui bossait à leur place donc
aujourd'hui on a reproduit système
sauf que les esclaves sont unanimes et
donc tant qu'on les a ça marche bien une
fois qu'on les aura plus qu'à se méfie
un peu la productivité agricole en
france a été multiplié par un facteur 8
depuis la dernière guerre 1945 deux
éléments majeurs pour ça qu'ils viennent
tous les deux de l'énergie les engrais
et les tracteurs sous la terre il ya une
quantité donnée de combustibles fossiles
et le stock ne sera pas réévalué en
cours de partie
on peut considérer que ce stock on ne
connaît pas exactement encore sur le
bout des doigts et mais la seule chose
qui est certaine à cause du processus de
formation c'est qu'il augmentera pas en
cours de partie quand vous tapez dans un
stock de départ qui est donnée une fois
pour toute et que vous ne pourrez plus
jamais réalimenter les mathématiques
vous disent que vous n'avez pas le droit
d'avoir en provenance de ce stock une
consommation indéfiniment croissante
vous n'avez même pas le droit d'avoir
une consommation indéfiniment constante
dans pareil cas vous n'avez qu'une seule
forme globale de courbes qui est
autorisé c'est que si vous remontez
suffisamment loin dans le temps la
consommation est nul
si vous allez suffisamment loin dans le
temps la consommation sera de nouveau
nul et quelque part entre les deux elle
passera par un maximum absolu alors le
pic s'applique ou s'appliquera au
pétrole au gaz au charbon mais il
s'applique aussi où s'appliquera alors à
l'étain ou tungstène au chrome os
vanadium offert à la bauxite et à la
potasse c'est pas de l'idéologie c'est
un tort innovâtes l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne en europe
est ce que vous voyez c'est qu'on est
passé par le maximum de cet
approvisionnement en fait il ya deux
temps jusqu'au choc pétrolier ça
augmente très vite à partir des chocs
pétroliers ça n'augmente plus jusqu'en
2006 et en 2006 c'est à dire deux ans
avant lehman brothers
ça commence à décroître sur plus de
concentration en co2 que nous avons créé
aujourd'hui sur plus de concentration
que nous avons créé aujourd'hui si
demain matin j'annulais les émissions
mondiales donc j'arrête totalement
d'émettre des gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde
demain matin eh bien le surplus que nous
avons déjà créé le fait de passer de 280
à 400 parties par million
au bout d'un siècle il vous reste encore
40 % de ce surplus au bout d'un
millénaire il vous reste encore 20 % de
ce surplus est au bout de dix mille ans
il vous en reste encore 10 % il n'existe
pas pour le changement climatique de
bouton reset le deuxième ordre de
grandeur que je voudrais vous mettre en
tête c'est ce que représente la
variation de température dont on est en
train de parler vous savez que les
médias arrêtent pas de vous dire on
risque 2° 3° etc alors en fait quand
vous entendez ça vous en foutez
complètement la température à paris
entre lille et réalité vers les 40
degrés vous êtes tous bien vivant du
reste sinon vous sauriez pas venu ici
donc deux degrés on s'en fout ça ne
parle pas avec nos sens 2° c vraiment
pas une menace
4 ou 5 degrés sur terre d'élévation en
un siècle c'est la guerre partout donc
il ya un risque sur la production
agricole
il ya un risque sur la stabilité des
écosystèmes ont pas besoin de ça il ya
un risque sur la prolifération de virus
et de bactéries qui n'existaient pas
avant
il ya un risque sur les événements
extrêmes thermique
il ya un risque sur l'élévation de
l'océan il ya un risque sur le ph
l'océan il ya un risque sur la
circulation océanique à grande échelle
il ya un risque sur l'intensité des
ouragans c'est une augmentation il ya un
risque sur la déstabilisation du
groenland et de la calotte antarctique
de l'ouest et ça c'est 3 à 6 mètres
d'eau dans l'océan de manière certaine
et si on dépasse les 2 degrés vous avez
également la calotte antarctique de
l'ouest qui est à risque et ça c'est 6
mètres d'eau dans l'océan
vous verrez après à quoi ressemble
europe du nord avec neuf mètres dos en
plus il ya un risque sur la remise en
circulation de stocks de carbone qui
était fixe depuis des milliers ou des
millions d'années voilà donc qui arrive
sur les hommes à l'arrivée 6015 on a
déjà émis deux mille milliards de tonnes
de co2 et donc je te dis que tu as déjà
signé pour 1,1 quelque chose de grand
même s'ils sont par là tout de suite tu
as signé pour donc les 1,5 degré qui
sont le talon bas de l'accord de pareil
vous oubliez ils sont déjà derrière nous
si vous voulez les deux degrés dont il
est question
alors physiquement c'est encore possible
à ce moment il faut se limiter à trois
mille milliards de tonnes de co2 dont
deux villes ont déjà été dépensés
donc les plus jeunes dans cette salle
jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
on le droit d'émettre collectivement
alors qu'ils sont 7 milliards la moitié
de ce que leurs grands-parents et leurs
parents ont émis pendant le siècle qui
s'est terminée il ya pas longtemps alors
qu'ils étaient en moyenne trois fois
moins nombreux à ce moment-là il
avoir rendu les émissions mondiales nul
quelque part dans la deuxième moitié du
xxième siècle d'où l'expression de
neutralité qui commencent à arriver
partout et il faut les avoir divisé par
trois d'ici à 2050 donc d'ici à ce que
mes enfants et mon âge c'est ça les deux
degrés vous avez aujourd'hui un
camembert qui vous donne la répartition
des émissions planétaires de gaz à effet
de serre grossièrement reconstitué par
votre serviteur en panachant les
énergies les machins les trucs et des
bidules c'est tout gaz à effet de serre
confondues c'est le co2 le méthane le
protoxyde d'azoté et les gaz halogénés
un peu plus de 20% des émissions
planétaires sont le fait des centrales à
charbon
vous avez 7 % des émissions planétaires
qui sont le fait des centrales à gaz et
un peu à fioul
vous avez 5 % des émissions planétaires
qui sont le fait des ciments qui est le
reste de l'industrie dans lequel la
syrie fait à peu près 4 % aussi sais
d'où je le reste c'est de la chimie de
base
et après le reste c'est des cacahuètes
les chaudières de bâtiment c 5 % les
transports c'est 14% dans lesquelles
vous avez à peu près 6 pour les voitures
à peu près 4 pour les camions à peu près
d'eux pour les bateaux et à peu près
d'eux pour les avions il suffira pas de
- pont de l'avion et de moins prendre sa
bagnole pour avoir réglé le problème
20% des émissions mondiales sont le fait
de manger alors là dedans qu'est ce qui
a vous avez les émissions directes de
méthane des ruminants
le méthane est un gaz à effet de serre
25 fois plus puissant que le co2 vous
avez également du protoxyde d'azoté qui
est un sous produit de l'utilisation des
engrais azotés canton les et pendant les
champs vous avez le métal des rizières
et vous avez les émissions de méthane
des déjections 9% des émissions
planétaires
c'est la déforestation qui est un
déterminant amont de la croissance
démographique et de l'alimentation
donc quand les agronomes vous dise on
peut nourrir 9 milliards d'hommes sur
terre les nourrir sûrement avec de la
biodiversité qu'il reste ça se discute
et enfin vous avez quelques potes de
perlimpinpin pour finir le reste la
gestion des déchets les chaînes du froid
etc